the country is in lockdown and we're
making huge personal sacrifices in our
everyday activities but Oxford
University scientists believe two-thirds
of us may already have had the virus
perhaps without symptoms and are
therefore immune so how do they work
this out
well they assume that one person will
infect to an ik or two others on average
so the virus quickly spreads and they
assume one person in a thousand is at
risk of severe disease now running the
numbers they conclude the virus started
spreading on the 27th of January four
days before the first confirmed UK cases
On January the 31st and 38 days before
the first death on March the fifth now
their math suggests that on the 19th of
March more than 45 million people will
have had the infection but those
advising the government are treating the
report with caution we simply don't know
at the moment and there that's why the
antibody test is so important so there
are estimates that up to 80% or more
people who Mohan weren't detected there
are estimates that of those who are
positive so that's a small percentage of
the population who were tested positive
quite a number of them were asymptomatic
in a town in Italy but we haven't we
don't know at a general population level
and that's why it's so important to get
this test in place that policy is to
stop the NHS being overwhelmed and to
save lives scientific advisors at
Imperial College in London calculate
that if the epidemic had been allowed to
run its course 500,000 people may have
died but that's likely to fall to around
20,000 but the tough social distancing
we're all living with and of course the
shielding of those most vulnerable to
serious consequences cases and death in
the UK are rising fast but the
government's chief scientist admits the
number of confirmed cases is just the
tip of the iceberg he estimates that for
every death that are around 1,000 cases
the vast majority undetected
which would mean 500,000 people have had
Coe bid 19 but if the ops of researchers
are right and two-thirds have had the
virus it should mean we've reached the
levels for herd immunity that would make
a second way
and infections less likely once the
social distancing rules are eased and if
that was confirmed by mass test from
unity we might just be able to return to
normal life sooner than some have
predicted